oh hang on a second i gotta i gotta make
my copy here
i'm gonna make my copy
because you guys know we give credit to
all the uh or try to give credits all
the tweets that we read and the the the
clips that we watch
this first one here is um marjorie
taylor green on steve bannon's traitor
tv
steve bannon's traitor tv
uh where she's
she's uh she bombs the t quote-unquote
i don't know
i hear i hear there's tale that she
likes to wear zip up hoodies
and carry backpacks full of
uh like lead pipes or something i don't
know there's something to that maybe i
allegedly
that that might be a thing that she
likes zip up hoodies
and she likes to take strolls on january
5th
through the city of washington dc maybe
i don't know there's snowballing here
people
so this is a clip again from
steve bannon's trader tv
and it's not very long but
you can hear that the guilt is oozing
out of these [ __ ] people you guys are
you guys know about the rolling stone
article the rolling stone article and
maybe we'll read a little bit of it um
here today
on the stream
maybe we'll go read a bit of it but that
the article
from
the rolling stone it really lays out
the
uh parts
of january 6 that were coordinated which
we we all suspected and
knew
these people are guilty of this because
they always project their guilt like
they constantly
constantly projecting their guilt
all the time they can't help themselves
they really can't [ __ ] help
themselves
so we knew so that we knew something was
afoot with you know mo brooks who wore a
bulletproof vest that day
paul gozar that joel jackson of a [ __ ]
uh you got uh uh andy biggs
um
you've got
marjorie taylor green and and lauren
bobert giving capital tours
uh for the insurrectionist you know
point out where specific important
things might be i don't know
actually gabe sanchez did a video on
this and he did it back in january
like that's how much that's how obvious
all this [ __ ] was
and it still is we're 10 months into
this
10 [ __ ] months
and it's still all obvious as hell
completely obvious
and we're still we're still debating
and still going round and round about
this now rolling stone prints it and all
of a sudden everyone's like oh my god
rolling stone printed it it's in black
and white so now we you know oh my god
it's more significant than when we
already knew what we know
so let's watch this [ __ ] hoof-footed
fool
um spew
diarrhea
seditious diarrhea
out of her mouth january 6 was just a
riot at the capitol and if you think
about what our declaration of
independence says it says to overthrow
tyrants
oh my [ __ ] god tyrants what are you
talking about number one
number one does she remember who the
[ __ ] president of the united states
was on january 6
is that the tyrant she's talking about
is that the [ __ ] tyrant you speak of
you you [ __ ] idiot what the [ __ ] is
she talking about the constitution says
to overthrow tyrants
well joe biden wasn't he couldn't be how
could he be a tyrant he wasn't even
sworn in as president i mean they were
trying to do everything they could to
stop
him to be president the duly elected
president now that's a tyrant so yeah
yeah do everything you can vote protect
democracy make sure our republic has
guard rails on it
like that kind of protect from
from [ __ ] authoritarian
bullshitters
like your mango mussolini jesus
you you
[ __ ] three-toed
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is she talking about
tyrants
donald trump was the president on
january 6th he was in power
that's your tyrant dummy
oh [ __ ] you can't
you can't even you can't even [ __ ] it
they really are [ __ ] dumb
they really are [ __ ] dumb
hey we're at this post on my feed uh
look at this uh art
that i i came up with um it was about
the uh
uh i posted something about uh sb8 out
of texas i believe
and someone's like oh well we vote every
two years i'm like no
no we vote all the time you're voting
all the time there's a there's an
election next week
in virginia against terry mcauliffe and
trumpkin
i mean yunkan but i mean yunkan is trump
younkin is trump
younkin is trump trump and junkin
younkin is trump so it's just trumpkin
and if you're not voting for terry
mcauliffe you're voting for fascism
you're voting for trumpism
fascism in a maga hat that's what you're
voting for if you don't vote for terry
mcauliffe
rather you don't go vote and you stay at
home because you don't think it's
important enough
or if you vote for any other candidate
any of them i don't care which one it is
i don't care who it is
you're voting for trumpism
terry mcauliffe is the only anti-trump
candidate on the ticket that's it that's
it that's what you got and that's that's
the best we got
is to vote anti-trumpism we have to
crush fascism
we have to crush fascism at the ballot
we're we're not succeeding at crushing
fascism on on social media we're not
succeeding in on uh crushing fascism in
these mission information forums the
universe of misinformation we're not
and we need to and we need to keep
pounding this and pounding it and
pounding it and pounding it and how we
win is at the ballot box we have to
[ __ ] vote go [ __ ] vote but the
most important thing is stay pissed stay
[ __ ] pissed [ __ ] these [ __ ]
because yeah you're gonna see
you're gonna see a [ __ ] uh clip today
of tim scott senator tim scott
of south carolina and kirsten cinema of
arizona
you're gonna see that clip and it's
gonna piss you right the [ __ ] off
because it pisses me off
it's not surprising that that's the way
that that it was handled in the airport
when a constituent approach approaches
their senator she wasn't talking to
[ __ ] tim scott tim scott's not her
[ __ ] senator
she was talking to her [ __ ] senator
and you're gonna see that clip
what happens is
christian kirsten cinema at kirsten
christian whatever it is senator cinema
of arizona
and senator tim scott of south carolina
are walking through the airport
and a constituent of cinema from arizona
approaches her and has concerns and is
asking her questions
and she doesn't just simply ignore and
walk on she gives a real smart ass
comment and then tim scott decides to
chime in so we're gonna watch that today
but the point of this is to stay pissed
you gotta [ __ ] stay pissed
and they gotta know we're pissed they
have to know we're [ __ ] pissed
so stay pissed
go [ __ ] vote
virginia
let's see what else we got oh if you
want it on like a hoodie or a uh a
sweatshirt i got t-shirts too
just go to store.d tonymichaels.com
or thetonymichaels.com and click on
merch and and there's the stay pissed a
lot of people like this so i was like oh
maybe i'll put it on some stuff anything
you buy in the merch store goes towards
the podcast um the production of the
podcast the equipment the the fees the
publishing fees all the money that we
spend on some editing and stuff that we
do
all that goes towards the the podcast
which uh the podcast speaking of that is
wednesdays three o'clock central four
o'clock eastern so tomorrow at four
o'clock eastern three o'clock central
time we're live on youtube twitter
twitch
and then it goes up on all the
directories
after we have we have done the live show
it gets posted on all the directories so
apple spotify you know all the normal
ones your favorite ones you can find it
on there
but it goes we go live
four o'clock eastern three o'clock
center on youtube twitter and twitch and
you go to thetonymichaels.com and find
all those places
the the apple the spotify the youtube
the twitch channel the twitter account
you find all those places where we
stream it
live
and also we have a guest episode on
friday i might mention that here too we
have a guest episode
on friday i'll announce tomorrow during
the live show who's gonna be
on our show i'm very excited to have her
on the show
um
she very excited to have her on the show
a lot of you will know her she's had
several videos
go viral
on instagram and tick tock
so a lot a lot of you will know who she
is
but
check that out too on friday so tomorrow
i'll announce who's gonna be our guest
on friday
but come check out tomorrow's podcast
wednesday tomorrow three o'clock central
four o'clock eastern
you guys know i don't have sound effects
on here so i did today oh here's the
video here we're already to it
the stay pissed at cinema video
this will make you stay pissed at her
so you see here uh let's let's
let's mute nancy's
let's uh make this bigger here
so you see they're in the airport here
and this is tim scott here and let me
make this bigger so you can see a lot
better boom there you go okay so this is
tim scott here in the suit and then in
the center frame and then kirsten
cinemas next to him in the stripes
and this lady here in the black
is the constituent
she's the one that's going to approach
kirsten cinema senator cinema
to uh to ask her some questions she has
some concerns so listen listen to the
response though
when they start when she starts walking
away
listen to the response of senator cinema
what she says to this constituent
i think it's uh
i know you've met the dozens
please don't touch me
ew gross
oh a constituent a peasant
ew
don't touch me
don't touch me
[Music]
really that's that's what you're going
to go with that you're that's your
response
not oh where where are you from in
arizona
or what district do you live in in
arizona
something like that something to clarify
that this lady's actually from arizona i
mean she may or may not be it's possible
someone could come up to kirsten cinema
and lie about where they live and who's
who they're a constituent of i mean i
doubt it
far-fetched
but i mean
don't touch me
you lowlife
wow okay well
let's see what else happens here listen
what tim scott says
sorry about this let me really apologize
to you for having one of the peasants
from arizona who is my constituent
asking me about questions that they're
concerned about of which i represent
them for
i'm real i really apologize for this
low-life constituent being so close to
us
don't touch me and tim cut says scott
says oh this is par for the course this
is par for the course these constituents
out there these voters out there they
vote for us and then when we don't say
we don't do what we say we're gonna do
they wanna ask us these silly things
called questions and they have these
things called concerns
you sons of [ __ ]
yeah par for the course [ __ ] write off
i can have them meet you next week
every single year in arizona it's
getting hotter and hotter we're breaking
breakfast
people are suffering your constituents
are suffering what are you going to do
about climate change
next week in glasgow could be the last
chance
please answer me senator
my family my house
from tucson or constituents
well she goes up the escalator and runs
off of course
of course she runs scared
i mean
par for the course right tim scott
right
par for the course
par for the course tim scat
[ __ ] idiots
so this is this is very typical of uh
of these senators who think their [ __ ]
don't stink and and and
to be completely unfair to set him up
her [ __ ] does stink
your [ __ ] does stink
senator cinema and also
i may add i may add that we that arizona
and we as debt democrats and people who
vote blue
are going to [ __ ] vote you out
at this point i mean you can try you can
try and redeem yourself but
you have been pretty [ __ ] shitty
for the hard work that all the people
who voted for you and worked on your
campaign to get you elected it's been
pretty shitty the way you've treated all
those people i doubt i doubt that those
people who voted for you and worked hard
to get you elected well [ __ ] forget
it
i highly doubt it highly [ __ ] doubt
it
so i mean i mean the the story here is
cinema thinks she has some kind of
[ __ ] voodoo power
over negotiations in the senate and
she's miscalculating completely just
like joe manchin's miscalculating here
as well that he has some super power
everyone thinks they have super powers
like oh they can they can veto a bill
before it even comes to the floor
[ __ ]
nah they don't have that power
chuck schumer holds the power to bring
the bills to the floor not [ __ ]
cinema or mansion
they don't hold those powers
now to be fair
if if chuck schumer can't whip the votes
then possibly he won't bring that bill
to the floor
to be debated and voted on that's a
possibility
i mean anything's a possibility here but
for them to run around acting like they
have this superpower of bringing a bill
to a floor or not it's just [ __ ] out
it's not it's not not a thing it's not a
thing they don't have the power to to
stop a bill from coming to the floor or
bring it to the floor chuck schumer can
bring a vote
that
is the power of the majority leader
and
by them being democrats it puts him in
that power
yeah
some people were
upset that she was hanging out with tim
scott in the airport which i'm not upset
about that i actually think i actually
think that's the problem here
is that you know republicans won't they
think democrats are the enemy
and their democrats think republicans
are the enemy fascists are the enemy
fascist so yeah if tim scott's gonna be
a fascist on an issue he's not on the
right side of an issue he's he's on the
wrong side of an issue if you're gonna
be a fascist absolutely you are going
that is what's gonna happen which
speaking of fascist um here's another
here's another here's another guy who
likes to pretend to
you know
be something that he's not all the time
mitt romney
you gotta hear what this this [ __ ] says
now you gotta remember uh you guys
remember who
do you guys remember who mitt romney is
you remember who
mitt romney is the the